[Musique]
ces ouvrières continue de transporter
les morceaux de feuilles jusqu'au gros
champignon qui abrite leur reine
elles l'ignorent mais elle s'apprête à
déménager ce qui est risqué aujourd'hui
c'est si on transporte que l'ennemi la
ville champignon et détruit le
champignon c'est la partie vitale sont
pas le champignon le champignon moment
la colonie marc garder ce petit morceau
de champignons ou éviter les écarts de
température la colonie vont être placés
dans un bac le bac vous placer à
l'intérieur de sacs et le tour être
transporté dans un camion de chauffer
jusqu'à l'université mais lieu cette que
les nino's à tout examen ici elle
environ huit ans d'âge ça ça - de ville
jusqu'à 10 ans étant donné leur nombre
plus de 15000 on peut dire que c'est 80%
des pensionnaires vivants qui ont quitté
l'insectarium dans cette seule boîte ce
certainement après la plus grande
proportion l'espèce la plus nombreuses
qu'on avait dans nos collections
vivantes mais s'en vont vers un endroit
où ils vont encore avoir une belle vie
et servir à la science
voici la reine d'une jeune colonie date
acéphale hôtesses et le son d'une de
celle qui la défendent dominé khoualed
prépare la relève pour le nouvel
insectarium qui ouvrira ses portes en
d'ici là il veillera à la croissance de
cette espèce de fourmi encore plus
spectaculaire ici and with despatie
radio canada montréal